Problem 15.
Let's see, they have a square.
It looks like a square.
I don't know if it's
a square just yet.
And they have a triangle
that comes off of
the square like this.
Ah, close enough.
And what do they tell us?
They tell us that this
is 90 degrees.
This is 60 degrees.
And this is A, B, C, D, and E.
And what other thing?
In the figure above, E, B, C, D
is a square, OK, and A, E is
equal to 8.
What is the area
of E, B, C, D?
So we just have to figure out
one side of the square.
And it's a square, so all
the sides are equal
and then we're done.
And this is actually just a
30-60-90 triangle problem.
How do I know it?
Because this angle is 60,
this is 90, so this
one has to be 30.
Or I could add it up to 180.
And if you don't even remember
what a 30-60-90 triangle is,
where they add up, you could
go back to page 838,
and they tell you.
If you look in the middle of
that page, they have special
right triangles, and they tell
you that if the hypotenuse is
2x that the side opposite the 30
degree side is x, and then
the side opposite the 60 degree
side is x square root
of 3, right?
So if x is equal to 8, what's
x squared of 3?
x squared of 3 is going to be
equal to 8 square roots of 3.
And, of course, this side will
be 2 times 8, which is 16.
I always think of the 30 degree
side as half of the
hypotenuse, and then the
60-degree side as square root
of 3 times the 30-degree side.
That's how I think about it.
But you can just look at
what they do on page
838 and you'll know.
If this is 2x, the side opposite
the 30-degree side is
x, And the side opposite the
60-degree side is x times the
square root of 3, so this
has to be 8 times the
square root of 3.
If this side is 8 square root
times the square root of 3,
then so is this side.
And so to figure out the area of
the square, you just say 8
times the square root of
3 times 8 times the
square root of 3.
And what does that equal?
That's 8 times 8, that's
64, times the
square root of 3 squared.
And what's the square root
of three squared?
That's just 3.
So it would become 64 times
3, and that's what?
180 plus 12, that's
equal to 192.
Next problem.
It's really good to become
comfortable with
the 30-60-90 triangles.
You'll probably get one or two
extra problems on the SAT if
you get really proficient
at that.
In a mixture of peanuts and
cashews, the ratio by weight
of peanuts to cashews is 5:2.
Peanuts to cashews, and that's
really the weight is 5:2.
How many pounds of cashews will
there be in four pounds
of this mixture?
How many pounds of cashews
there'll be in 4 pounds of
this mixture?
So we know that cashews
plus peanuts is
going to be 4 pounds.
And we also know-- I could
multiply both sides of this
equation by C, this top one.
We also know that peanuts are
going to be 5/2 the number of
cashews, right?
Because the weight of peanuts
to cashews is 5:2.
So peanuts is going to
be 5/2 of cashews.
And the cashews plus the
peanuts is equal to 4.
So why don't we just substitute
this in for this?
So we get cashews plus 5/2
of cashews is equal to 4.
And what is this equal to?
This is equal to dot common
denominator 2.
This is like one
cashew, right?
So that's 2/2 plus 5/2 cashews
is equal to 4.
So going up here, that's
7/2 times cashews is
equal to the 4.
Let's multiply both sides
of this times 2.
So then you get 7 cashews
is equal to 8.
Divide both sides by 7, you get
cashews is equal to 8/7
pounds, right?
8/7 pound, so 1 and 1/7 pound
is going to be cashews.
And this stuff here, I could
just multiply both sides by
2/7, times 2/7.
This would have canceled out,
and I would have gotten the
same thing, 8/7.
So there are 8/7 pounds
of cashews here.
Next problem.
Kind of an odd number, but I
think on these free answer,
they sometimes give you problems
that might have not
the most clean numbers
just to trip you up.
OK, so that's the y-axis.
That's my x-axis.
After this problem and the
next, I will go to bed.
So, let's see, that's
the y-axis.
And then they drew
a line here.
It looks something like that.
They call that line l.
They draw another
line like this.
Let's see, this is A, this is
B, and they say that this
point right here is
the point 8, 3.
OK.
line m, not shown, passes
through the origin, that's o,
and intersects A, B
between A and B.
What is one possible value
of the slope of line m?
So line m intersects at the
origin and intersects this
line someplace.
It's going to look something
like this.
So the whole issue here is that
this line is going to
have a lower slope than this
line, than line l.
So what is the slope
of line l?
Well, it goes through the point
8, 3, and it also goes
through the point 0, 0.
So what's the slope of line l?
Change in y over change in x.
3 minus 0 over 8 minus 0
is equal to 3/8, right?
So this slope is 3/8.
So in order for this slope-- it
has to be less than this.
And it's also going to be
greater than 1, right?
Because it's still in the first
quadrant, so it's still
going to be in this range.
So what's a slope that's less
than 3/8 and greater than 1?
Well, I don't know.
2/8, which equals 1/4?
That would work.
That's less than 3/8
and greater than 1.
I mean, you could say 1/8.
That would work.
1/16 would work.
1/1,000 would work.
Any of those, that's all
possible values for the slope
of m because they just say
it intersects A, B
between A and B.
It doesn't say where.
So any line, you know, it
could look like this.
The line could look really
small, so that would be like a
slope of 1/1,000, but
it would still work.
Next problem, problem 18.
OK, so they gave us a table.
So they say year, number
of students.
And then they go 92,
93, 94, 95, 96.
In 92, there was x, then 1,552,
1,238 1,459, and 1,351
The table above shows student
enrollment in Weston High
School from 1992 to 1996.
If the median enrollment for the
five years was 1,351-- so
this is the median; this is the
middle number-- and no two
years have the same enrollment,
what is the
greatest possible value for x?
So 1,351 has to be the
middle number.
Let me make another
list. 1,351 has to
be the middle number.
And let's see, what are the
numbers that we know are
definitely greater?
We have 1,451, and then
we have 1,552.
And the numbers that
are less, we know--
so this is the median.
We know that 1,238 is less.
And we know that if 1,351 is
the median, then x is also
going to have to be less than--
there has to be two
numbers less than 1,351, so x
has to be less than 1,351,
although x could be
here as well.
It could be larger than 1,238.
So we know that x is
less than 1,351.
And it could have been equal
to 1,351, but they tell us
that no two years have
the same enrollment.
So what is the largest
possible value for x?
Well, it's 1,350, right?
Because you know that's the
largest number that's less
than 1,351.
And then this would
be 1,350 here.
And then 1,351 would still
be the median.
And we are done!
I'll see you in the
next section.